[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to wrap up our conversation
real quick and then get to you no guys
welcome back to the break room it's our
daily show that keeps you updated on
just what's going on in nerd news from
our actual break room that we've taken
over we're slowly you guys are going to
see little improvements as we go it's
getting a little bit better and better
and more hospitable to people who are
not literally currently on this show
because this is actively our real break
room there are complaints there's
plastic
i haven't like taken a break in here
there have been no breaks only worked in
here uh uh this is this entire time uh
i'm not supposed to be here normally i'm
filling him for somebody but also uh
aggressively uh to control the show and
i'm telling you that coming up on the
show uh we're gonna talk about black
mirror uh we haven't seen that uh
anything of that in three years was the
last time we saw anything about black
mirror also aladdin 2 has some news that
apparently we're going to cover gotta
read it word for why all right uh
i have i don't want to mess them up okay
black mirror haven't seen her
in three years
that's what you wanted it's totally
worth it go back i have to get these
jokes aladdin 2 just got rocked
i don't know what that's referencing
got it how about this one the academy
like my ass just won't quite
uh uh the academy just won't quit uh
also uh trailer dropped and uh we have
leaks and teases for the boys she-hulk
and the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special and also we're gonna play a
little tmz uh with a little bit of hot
goss remember you guys did you guys ever
see voskos ooh it was an old segment
somebody's gonna find it in the comments
of voskos and it was eric doing a very
sassy character that just uh spits the
latest uh voskos but uh and this time
i'm gonna be the harvey levin uh but in
the meantime hey who else is here how
about that cuddlestone your boy happy
monday everybody thrilled to be here
well no one's buying that
yeah i don't know uh whitney van
laningham so nice to see you hello it's
good to see you welcome back i'm the
other person who's not on this show
normally yeah we both didn't make the
cut and yet didn't make the cut for
first season series regular yeah for
seasons one through six so we have no
arcs yeah
uh but uh the main villain of the season
jessica clemons
um i did make the cut yeah she did i'm
here
she sliced it all up uh and i already
said i'm phillip molina uh also by the
way the way super chats are working is
that they go into our reverse swear jar
uh and the way the reverse swear jar
works is anytime it hits a hundred bucks
we've earned a swear word uh fastest
finger on that uh
to uh whoever sees it first um right now
we have no we're not even close to being
able to use a swear word so if you do
use a swear what happens you get cut
john gets really mad at you after the
show i learned and then he again talks
to you about it before this show and
reminds you whitney you're not allowed
to
freaking do that he calls your parents
no he like he called my my parents are
on vacation right now and john called
them
they got a facetime from their hotel
room it's gonna go on your permanent
record yeah i think yeah i want to show
off your parents being on vacation hey
let's do some headlines
as we'll begin every episode with some
headlines and then the nerdy news that
you need to know
season six of black mirror is in the
works as philip kind of hinted at we
just got confirmation uh it's been about
three years since the last season of
black mirror she's not feeling it and
she's going to step out
just this sucks
all right way to go zach
has to go to the tech booth here for
some microphone issues but um uh yeah we
were just talking about it we got that
bander snatch yeah i was gonna say
banter interactive movie was great i
didn't
do it i didn't watch it or do it i got
stressed without it it was it seemed
like a lot of work and i was like i want
to have a good experience with it and i
over thought it i also haven't seen dune
for the same reason oh okay okay i
haven't seen dooney there for that
reason but bander's snatching i want to
get it just not stressful i can't just
like take an edible and it's like 45
minutes a year and i will say like the
cool thing about vaynersnatch and we're
going off the rails here a little bit
already as is that no that is the custom
here on the break room uh the the rails
are made of noodles here um
is one of the coolest things like a
streaming service has done as far as
like using the ability to like choose
your own adventure whatever but um we're
getting this new season it's going to be
longer than the most recent season
um and from the same charlie brooker i
believe is the guy's name he's made all
the uh whose mind is a freaking weird
place i also love his his reasoning for
why it's taken this long to get a new
season is during covet he was like i
don't think uh everybody needs to be
reminded about like alternate awful
realities right now thank you charlie
brooker
in other news now this is a total rumor
okay no confirmation on this uh the
website giant freaking robot has
reported that dwayne johnson is
currently in talks to join aladdin too
and the rumor is that
it's going to be to be the [ __ ]
genie baby
[Applause]
oh he caught it
thank you uh
painter
i'm sorry i'm not uh pronouncing your
name and gaming arachnid we did just hit
the hundred dollars on the swear jar
mostly uh 99.99
of the effort uh on that uh f-bomb goes
to the paint painty monty yes sorry the
the color of uh the background of your
super chat is making it hard to read but
we appreciate you i got my nasty little
swear hand now we're moving hot
so as i was saying that
is by far the best adjective to just
throw one of the things that it doesn't
belong on yeah
yes yes
but as i was saying before i rudely
interrupted myself um
the rumor is that he might be replacing
will smith as the genie now will smith
of his own volition is supposedly
stepping away from some projects might
might be including aladdin too i mean
hey if you've got to replace will smith
pulling the uh dwayne the rock johnson
breaking case of emergency is a pretty
cool i love that that's the back up for
will smith is like another brown man
that's just like
rock johnson calls himself franchise
viagra that is the truth
they're replacing will smith because of
an association with violence
with the rock with the rock who is just
who literally put the smackdown
on your candy asses for years
johnson dwayne johnson doesn't slap
anybody the rock rock probably so
we don't know what's taking place in vin
diesel's trailer can you tell that i
love him and i will write her for
twitter smith is the name of the
character from fresh prince of bel-air
to be clear oh what's his real name it's
also will smith but actually one of them
is short for i found this out i think
one of them short for william and the
other one's like willard williams oh wow
that's the differentiation one short for
willennium um
our uh uh good friend of the show never
appeared on it but he's invited
he's watched our videos oh he tweeted at
me and mt when he watched our video that
one time yeah and then i hit him up on
instagram did not respond okay hey
samuel if you're if you're watching my
man we love canadians here we love
action stars we love mcu actors there's
a lot of reasons for you to come on the
show
but he was speaking with uh gq uk
recently and uh
okay you said it on me and he uh
he mentioned he's gonna be in the
upcoming barbie movie that like sound
that sounds every time i say oh it's
gonna be some silly little movie but
like there's a lot of big time act like
uh greta gerwig is the director and the
writer uh ryan gosling uh margot roby
like there's a crazy cast for this it's
not margaret robert
[Laughter]
damn it yeah
uh and simu is playing some as of yet an
unknown role in the movie and uh i just
he had this great quote that the reason
he took the role is because it was one
of the best scripts he's ever seen i bet
it's really good did greta and write it
yes
and the little women with uh timothy
chalamet and sirsha ronan yeah i mean
she's on a high street little women
nasty little women
apparently uh he's been having to do a
lot of dance rehearsals movies not a
musical but maybe he has a big dance
sequence he has a he has a background in
a hip-hop dance and i'm not joking he
actually is a hip-hop book and we know
he did a lot of martial arts training
for sean cheese
yeah he's my favorite he's my favorite
reminder of like what people did to get
to hollywood does that make sense like
they still had to do
anything anything they still had to do a
bunch of arts and everything so like the
stock footage him learning how to dance
he probably can also do like
tweeting like kevin feige like uh yeah
yeah yeah he did everything it's not
appropriate but it's still my favorite
phrase of thomas jane saying when he was
struggling okay he would let a man buy
him a sandwich
and that's all i'll say about what that
is you can google that if you'd like uh
thomas jade uh
the uh this is an ongoing story that is
by far one of them the stupidest and
most hilarious stories i love covering
here i love them so you know zack snyder
won two different kind of honorary
oscars right like there was the the um
flash breaking the the speed force
moment
oscar cheer moment and then he won i
think for best army of the dead one the
other like
fan v fan favorite award uh and so you
know there was this report by the rap
recently saying that like a lot of that
was done by twitter bots and and the the
academy awards has come out and been
like no no not twitter bots we vetted we
banned anybody accused of suspicious
activity and it's like this is clearly
the academy saying like you know trying
to unembarrass themselves
for like a pretty embarrassing thing oh
my god i'm not if the academy's watching
even better
the academy is a bunch of older people
with the same old bias with the same old
traditions so no one should ever look at
the academy awards and say this is top
tier award ceremony stuff
they don't understand how to do it for
today's people when they thought going
to the internet was a great idea that's
the worst idea you could have done
you're gonna get every troll and the man
the producer of the academy awards is
like no we're giving it to we're giving
the voices back to the people and i'm
like you could easily do that without
making it this way
so let us name another mountain dew
flavor yeah
or just make an actual category for like
superhero movies
like
musicals and animations no shots at
army of the dead or uh zack snyder's
justice league right like we enjoyed
those movies as well but like these are
categories in which it beat avengers end
game spider-man no way home like the the
best cheer moment was for all movies of
all time it beat the matrix like i mean
come on guys well that's the personal
bias the side of zach
should never come above anything the
spoon bends and you're just like hell
yeah oh yeah my my hands hurt from
clapping
time come on be in the history of the
world that deserves accolades don't you
say yeah
i knew you were gonna say and you know
you're gonna say
it you grant did some fabulous work in
that uh speaking of not old people it's
jessica's mom's birthday today happy
birthday linda um
[Music]
i have a relationship with her oh stop
it stop eating you don't want me
no you're not gonna feel bad i don't
want to embarrass you i don't want to
embarrass you at your job
linda
i care about you god she's gonna watch
us and be like oh he's talking about i'm
really happy for you on your special day
well and we bring her up because uh
she's a fan of the boys boys season
three trailer dropped today
uh a lot of great stuff in there
actually our editor riley said he had to
stop watching halfway through because he
felt like he was giving away too much of
the plot of season three yeah there's a
lot it gives away a lot
it's maybe the most violence i've ever
seen in a trailer there's so much head
squishing and blood spatter in this
trailer looks great we're gonna be
covering the boys here on new rock stars
heavily i love this detail that you guys
just got a second ago about how hard it
can be to work at new rockstar sometimes
where our editor was like yeah i'm not
going to watch that trailer and then
i'll i awkwardly have to go no you have
to watch the trailer for the video that
we're
making it is a good warning to give
though to the audience of like it does
give a lot away so
the black phone is another one that's
like a great horror movie that trailer
literally gave out the entire plot of
the movie and and this show does as well
so maybe
watch it which to be fair i mean it
might be one of those things too where
this is might be like an eight-episode
you know season maybe they're just
giving away the entire plot of the first
two episodes or something like that
there's a lot of
those violent scenes were like so good
but there's so many that i was like this
there's one big plot point in there that
i was like i wish they didn't give this
away i wish i would have saw this later
in the show and we won't give that away
though yeah probably later on
but uh a lot of great footage of jensen
echols as uh soldier boy am i
pronouncing his last name correct older
boy
thank you yeah uh soldier boy
um no get him out no get him out and
that wasn't even the right move that
wasn't even the right move
he does the superman
all right you said
i can't no
oh zag you have a rumor out of us
like this one i'm not i can't do it
either legally as a white woman but you
know the other one but zach
yeah uh but
in summation i know how to dance the
boys season three looks great um linda
you know that uh i also enjoy dancing
and
stop take you on the town and show you
uh out of the close-ups
let's get even closer no go keep going
and in our in our second favorite dumb
ongoing storyline um
that we reported last week there's this
rumor that uh the spider-man reference
in the end credit scene of morbius had
been cut out
that rumor has apparently been debunked
apparently the reference is still in the
digital release that has come out of
morbius though we would like to start
the rumor
that one in ten
versions of the digital release of
morbius has that removed there's no way
you can prove us wrong unless you're
going to buy 10 copies of the digital
release of morbius i like that we're not
like just go buy a bunch of cupcakes i'd
be like please don't that'd be weird
i've got six already
give me an excuse
do you guys sell this on uh floppy disks
would be so good on vhs with like the uh
original blade
soundtrack oh they'd probably probably
have a great box cover too
you know that is in no way indicative of
what the movie's really like you know
yeah hell yeah like a lot of the best uh
disney plus uk their account
accidentally might have leaked the uh
release date for she-hulk which we've
been expecting it to be sometime late
summer early fall something like that
right that'll be the the next marvel
series after miss marvel but supposedly
august 17th is when it's going to
premiere and along with that release
date they gave us kind of an official
synopsis which i think is this is the
first time we've gotten this and it kind
of confirmed a couple things we'd been
suspecting but it it confirmed it it is
going to be a comedy series cool
different
yes
jennifer walters is going to get her
powers from her cousin bruce banner from
an emergency blood transfusion
that's what happens in the comics so
apparently they're gonna keep that uh we
know touchdown and mazlani it was great
in orphan black and uh the first season
of um
that hbo show um
what is your favorite
show the one set in the twenties
uh
the chat
um
it was a remake of an old uh man in the
house harry mason perry mason scott
perry uh perry mason i did not watch
that i didn't know deep deep cut we
didn't do breakdowns on the channel
i was like three years ago but oh the
kind of content i watch might be might
be indicative of an old person um oh and
uh we got confirmation i think this
might have been announced before tim
roth coming back as abomination
abomination's been sneaking into a lot
of stuff like that yeah i love those
little sprinkles of abomination it's fun
great gig for tim ross too i wonder if
uh you know william hurt r.i.p i wonder
if they're like going to shift over some
of that character world building that
they were doing in that direction and
maybe tim roth as well oh good point
yeah
yeah oh yeah
instead of going with thunderbolts
you're doing kind of a variation on that
vibe yeah right yeah we already saw
abomination come back once yeah chung
chi speaking of shanghai um patrick
stewart uh did an interview this week
where he talked about he was unsure
about coming back as professor x and you
know he's mentioned this a couple of
times just because he had such a great
conclusion to that character in logan
right and where you get to
die in hugh jackman's arms and just like
oh
and then
finally
uh
coming back to uh oh not not yet coming
back to the thing by the way we are
going to get to that uh thor 11 thunder
image that just came out like 20 minutes
ago we're going to talk about that in a
second here but um finally uh phillips
friend heavy spoilers uh releasing
details about oh wait
friend
acquaintance you know heavy's favorite
guy's like frenemies i know how yeah
we're toxic in front of me
shout out heavy spoilers come on the
show uh
get a plane ticket and get out here
buddy uh um he released some details
about an alternate opening of multiverse
of madness supposedly there was a
scrapped opening scene that had mordo
visiting wanda and her killing him
we were just talking about this right
before the show started this is 616
mortals yes so this is what's crazy
about this yes i know
i know heavy spoilers
all right well you can ask me any
questions you want later uh but what
he's actually referencing is the dude
had the entire plot of multiverse of
madness a year ago and there's a video
of his you can watch and he lays out the
whole freaking movie
very very accurately one of the only
differences the opening is mordo uh
being killed by wanda yeah there's a
couple there's also an illuminati
difference that i think maybe we're
going to get into we're getting into
that not today you know how much that
would be if i saw six one six mardo get
just
murdered quick especially
built up and it's like i'm gonna go
after the sorcerers or whatever and then
i don't know what he's doing if they
kill him before i find out i'm gonna be
mad i like that he's just hanging back
and he's like y'all figure that out you
guys go fight i mean i think brandon's
pointed out on the show mordo seems to
be right so far
you know wanda is certainly proving him
right did nothing wrong thanos that's
right immortal did nothing wrong thanos
is right uh we should get a mordo no
didn't do anything wrong shirt oh yeah
or just a picture of mordo at my desk
that'd
next we're getting into our thumbnail
which i don't think we have a graphic
for it but i said it anyways um we're
gonna discuss the thor love and thunder
photo that just released like uh maybe
30 to 45 minutes ago uh let's go ahead
show it john punch in
okay hold on to this photo hold on to
this photo for a minute daschle get up
and move away from your desk sorry uh
stay on that photo john stay on our
photos make a better door in a window
so this thorn love thunder photo just
kind of dropped recently
and it is a spectacular image that shows
uh jane to the right clearly buffed out
natalie portman and valkyrie
the posture the posture
so this is my theory and i want to hear
your guys's takes too i do really have
deep thoughts that that's bass that's
the god
right hand in the bottom right hand
corner and at first i was thinking oh
why would uh like jane why would mighty
thor and why would valkyrie be above her
i think all the very important gods are
on the bottom floor and then everyone
else is above them
yeah this could be like a um a palpatine
in the senate kind of situation right
where there's a bunch of rows of these
kind of thrones maybe zeus is somewhere
there right now
do you guys think this is a new asgard
or do you think this is olympus well
that certainly would not make sense this
is blowing my mind up fast with it right
like yeah yeah so it's like all the gods
so do they have is olympus the only
place where it could house all of them
well
i think well new asgard is is new and it
it doesn't look bad from there but
[Applause]
it feels like it's like uh you know
adjacent to animal kingdom or something
like it doesn't feel very fancy right i
don't think yet well that's what i was
thinking from the images from new asgard
i'm like yeah they're still rebuilding
but watch the inside be impeccable
because they only know what they've seen
on the old asgard and old asgard was
just
it felt like the roman like
yeah
it was gorgeous so watch the inside just
be phenomenal
how to decorate baby
yeah um i do love this especially
because like we've seen a representation
of bast in black panther right just as a
panther guy right as kind of a physical
panther god so then to like um personify
the god in an actual personhood would be
an interesting take
they did pretty well with the image if
you want to put it up again john so
sorry to me to keep doing this she has
like the cat ears she has the the black
cat ears the gold accents are just like
a dead giveaway also the woman the
actress is phenomenally breathtaking um
i really just want that person to be a
goddess and so that's why i'm writing
really hard that this could be best if
chrissy is in the chat chrissy can also
maybe back up my opinion
but um so we're trying to figure out
whether or not that might be new asgard
or olympus we're also trying to figure
out which this might just be me is
where is this taking place on the
spectrum of moon night well oh on
spectrum oh so i was going to say an
anime convention because of the ears
but no where is it on
timelines because i remember that in
moon night they were like oh we had a
lot of stuff to put in the script for
thor but then they were like uh we don't
have to do it so i didn't know if moon
knight came first or if thor well moon
knight would come first in that
implication right because then they
don't have to worry about what happens
after them well they were thinking about
doing it and then they took it out so
what could they have taken it out
because they were planning on putting
some of the goddess gods that we didn't
see in moon knight in this because we
didn't see bass in moon night so i'm
like there's a couple gods that we
didn't see in moonlight that they talked
about that we could be now seeing and
thor loving their version of the any ad
was like kind of like slightly it was
all from it was a version of the ad um
so i was also wondering about that like
if we'd see those other
yeah it'd i really want them to
anything that's like getting confusing
in the indian and who's on or whatever i
would love for them to be like okay
let's clear all this up or whatever yeah
you guys are gods you guys call
yourselves gods but you're not like just
like let us all know but you know what
everybody gets to have a throne
everybody gets a throne you know
just hang out john made a funny theory
that he was like what if uh mighty thor
is the avatar for bass and i was like
that'd be very funny but i don't think
it is in this case funny
you know funny well you don't have an
interesting take on that term uh
you know the way it is a white person
playing an avatar oh yeah okay hold on
producer john coming to defend himself
i thought maybe the woman standing in
front of them was bast's avatar so the
the person yeah
oh
oh you thought yeah
as a black person i didn't think there
was coral in it so clearly i'm the one
that's i don't know i'm the bad person
here and i'm sorry i'm sorry i spoke
with you
guys i'm very comedy adjacent yeah i do
like though to his credit uh producer
john pointed out everybody's looking
very serious in that photo and it has a
vibe now maybe it's some kind of a
senate situation of all the gods it also
has a little bit of a trial energy yeah
like maybe they're like a uh you know a
panel of judges judging somebody or
something like that i wonder if we're
just seeing natalie portman and we're
like senate vibes
well i think this this has to be the
truck okay two things that i think it
could be it's either the trial for thor
trying to come back and being like
something bad is happening or it's them
talking about gore the god butchers
coming yeah gore could be leaving
preparing for war kind of yeah that's
why i'm like i'm leaning as a new asgard
because i'm like gorg i already got to
olympus and only a couple people maybe
you know would be awesome is that
meeting where they're like trying to say
like no this is serious he's coming like
no it's not serious it's not serious any
attacks during it yeah oh my he breaks
through there and he's like give me the
head of everyone in this room
yeah i'm very serious
[Laughter]
there's a lot of money to pay somebody
just to do mo cap he didn't pay me at
all
this is actually this this works well
the one thing i noticed in that photo
and
spamaron spam spammer anne i don't know
how to pronounce your name also notices
what's up with the nice whiskey wicker
basket of grapes between jane and
valkyrie i'm gonna correct you photo
again i'm gonna correct you spray marine
i believe that is a cornucopia of grapes
okay that's still
wait is that cornucopia not a can it
also be a basket yes well cornucopia can
be woven but a cornucopia is horn-shaped
right comes from the greek term uh
referring to a horn of plenty
based on like uh supposedly the horn uh
the god zeus was fed from a goat's horn
as a baby okay and now we have copious
and corn bean horn yeah kind of sure um
so and it's just it's very god-like it
also could be more evidence this is that
olympia this is olympus olympus olympia
olympia is your
you can call me in olympus or wait no
you can call me an olympian
athletic uh also a quick shout out to uh
uh dominique thompson said katy perry is
in the uh love and thunder trailer is
she really
uh is it really her is it something that
just somebody let us know if katy perry
is randomly it might need its own
breakdown if that's true katy perry
performing for the olympian godzilla do
you think that it's just like the
deleted footage of her from get him to
the greek you're
taken out it's just her walking down the
staircase
past jonah hill and then that's now in
thor 11. you know
somebody just asked in the chat what uh
your favorite cuss word is i think is
arachnid gamer i think it's a [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
we just hit another 100 bucks on the
swear jar i was trying to set myself up
i end up just setting up jessica
wait it's only one it is only one it's
only one one word if you say it i did
i've probably tried to hyphens and the
second time you said it was just a
replay of the audio the first time you
said it there you go that was close
otherwise we have to call whitney's
parents and we're on vacation they're on
vacation
hard to get them yeah you've been saying
that for a long time
on vacation uh speaking of vacation we
want to do a quick shout out to some
folks who helped us bring uh this
episode to you and those are our good
friends at baksu now you might be stuck
at home maybe you live in the midwest
maybe you live in the deep south
wherever you live maybe you can't get to
japan but you'd like to travel there via
snack hell yeah okay
yeah it's the most delicious way for
sure yeah bakzu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door each
baku features a new theme providing a
gourmet journey through japan so the
first boxer you receive is the seasons
of japan one that we have here and it's
got i mean it's really a speaking of
cornucopia it's a real treasure chest
yeah i found this one already including
uh it also comes with uh this great
booklet that not only it teaches you a
little bit about the japanese snacks and
some of the history the cool thing about
baku is they work with these old-school
snack makers often they're kind of small
family owned deals that have been around
for hundreds of years
like jessica is holding a little
moki deal called the muchan dengo mochi
give me one of the mochi no i want them
another emoji they look delicious uh so
the seasons of japan the whole deal with
this box that you get is it there are
snacks in here representing all four
seasons
of japan this this uh the moki kind of
represents spring because um
mochi thank you um
because they're you know little sticky
rice dumplings enjoyed during the spring
hanami or flower viewing season in japan
strawberry oh
just a strawberry
it's a freeze-dried strawberry
infused with white chocolate supposedly
oh dude that was really good it looks
great these are really good
that mochi is so good
we will not be eating all of these
snacks on camera we will get to them
today okay but we're actually going to
be eating uh boxers all week here on the
break room are we supposed to save some
of this no no we've got other boxes go
to town phillip uh we don't want anybody
getting low blood sugar during the
taping of the break room
spicy yes i think that's one of the uh
winter snacks
winter snacks uh represent um
or fall or something like that uh but
we're gonna be eating different boxes we
actually have different boxes you're
gonna be trying out you should grab
yourself a box sue as well maybe give it
as a gift to a good friend to try one
out
and support us here at the break room
and at new rockstars click the link in
the description and use code rockstars
to get 15
off your order thank you to boxu this
one
oh my god oh my god i don't know that is
a don don yaki i'm going to mispronounce
everything apologies the best thing i've
ever had in my no i'm sorry it's an
edamame sanbai oh my god your mom would
love this summer harvested edamame bits
baked into a cracker yeah it looks great
so good that
you catch me later enough at night i'm a
big cracker you know what i'm talking
about okay
all right we also want to shout out
though this is all very good and this is
a very thoughtful gift for someone yes
yeah if you have a friend that maybe
maybe a friend that likes anime or or uh
japanese media or just who took a trip
to japan and loves their snacks
well while my co-hosts are snacking out
i'm gonna uh uh promote our latest
obsession shirt at newrockstarsmerch.com
this is the one inspired by multiverse
of madness it's called shattered madness
uh philip pointed out the other day that
um the the cracks in this kind of uh
represent or they match similar to the
cracks in dr strange's watch that's kind
of a little hidden easter egg um there's
a couple other little easter eggs if you
grab this shirt new rockstarsmerch.com
also
we're showing off some of the latest
merch from the epic hero shop here on
the table
oh i was gonna say oh
my co-hosts are rocking some uh they're
called soup cans but soup is in
superhero thought i rejected that name
okay well i think i made it onto the
website philip uh
they're little can koozies in the style
of superheroes grab one of these take it
to the uh fourth of july uh picnic take
it to the labor day barbecue take it to
the streets take it to the streets oh i
told you why did you take it i was
saying that for me
i i'm so sorry give me the rest of it
i'm trying to give you the rest of the
lab okay children okay children there's
snacks for everyone well there wasn't
anything we've got to learn to share
we've got to learn to share oh my god
also someone in the chat said eat a blue
chew in all caps there's a lot of
reasons we can't do that baby no reason
philip has done it before
i'll do it again it'll kill me
yeah they said that like ladies aren't
allowed to take it apparently i don't
need it i don't need it as long as i
have these treats that i want to get
horny during my day
i want it
are we
speaking to horny during our day
are we talking about daniel craig in
this episode
is that later
what are we doing
you can talk about them right now okay i
uh uh real quick want to touch on the
fact that uh what i was referencing
earlier about heavy um spoilers is that
a lot of people uh are now realizing
that potentially daniel craig was going
to be on the illuminati
and one uh people think that it was
gonna be mr fantastic it was actually
just be daniel craig i don't know if you
guys have seen this amazing interview
with elizabeth olsen
with the john krasinski
i don't know who that is
uh that they didn't film any of that
with her yeah um but uh uh so supposedly
daniel craig was like ready to go except
heavy spoilers the only person saying
i've been getting the character's name
is it balder the brave or something like
that and
that it was gonna be that character i
guess and it wasn't it was like they had
already done a costume that uh it was
just like a timing thing or something
they were like there's uh too many old
british people in there we can't put
another one in potentially um but i'm
glad that they didn't because that
instead of mr fantastic who is like was
such a good i think daniel greg should
wait wait for like a really big name
like how doctor strange did doctor how
benedict cumberbatch is doctor strange
hold off for a minute
they're going to get you and there's a
little bit like even if they'd had both
krasinsky as reed richards and daniel
craig as bulger the brave there's like
it's an embarrassment of riches at that
point there's too many it's too many
cameos it's just like yeah you're giving
your best ideas daniel craig again
daniel craig is too good to be like
mixed just let him be a solo let him be
a christian bear what do you think's in
this part
oh my god it looks like someone's having
too much fun that is a forbidden snack
she's trying to set me up for mandatory
fun but instead i'm gonna eat a
all dessert god it's time for mandatory
fun uh what's really fun about this is
that this is a segment that tommy
clearly wrote for himself
to uh discuss you should read it and i'm
gonna read it uh as tommy
it's time for mandatory fun the segment
where genius philanthropist and
world-class love tommy bechtold forces
his three best friends to have some fun
with him today we're going to gossip
town
tmz can't be the only gossip brand out
there so welcome to bmz
with all the hot geek goss you can
swallow
we heard the rumor about daniel craig
supposedly playing reed richards or
balder the brave from our dear friend
heavy spoilers but instead
i need you all to stand up and pitch me
stand up stand up oh stand up oh right
oh my thighs oh wow um you okay baby
no you ate my damn cracker
we're replicating the tmz office right
now yeah uh give me the straw i'm a
harvey levin now uh i need you all to
stand up and pitch me your juiciest
sweetest gossip casting rumors the
winner gets a seat
oh all right
let's hear these pictures what do you
got okay i got one for you sir so we we
uh we found uh jonah you know this guy
jonah hill outside of the cvs on beverly
in fremont uh he was coming out with
some uh
iron ironers and
what's an ironer it's one of those
things you know old people use to do
their clothes and iron and yeah only old
people iron their glasses ah shut up
shut up
this actual zack huddleston that worked
with tmz this is the pmc office baby
um and we said hey hey jonah jonah jonah
when we gonna see you again what are we
gonna see you again he said uh catch me
in the next judd apatow batman picture
i'll be playing catwoman jonah hill as
catwoman i said what yeah henry would
love this you henry no you i i said that
when i heard the news harvey
oh henry is a candidate yeah
and oh it's delicious harvey's gonna
love oh god i said it again no it's
harvey yep all right
well uh it was started strong and it
ended weird so much happened tonight
yeah all right all right i can see it i
can see it oh jonah hill as a as
catwoman
okay a role that's clearly currently
recently been cast uh but okay
uh what else we got any other pitches
from paige come on we need to cover okay
i i got one uh our our reporters were
down at lax okay a plane landed from
atlanta coming in from the set of the
most or the upcoming mcu film hasn't
even been announced yet fantastic four
getting off that plane
timothy chalamet the god okay
ian comma the god or is that part of the
name shalom may the god
and and uh um you know nobody knew what
what he was doing in atlanta until they
saw just a little bit on his neck a
little bit of
silver paint
yes timothy chalamet cast as silver
surfer an upcoming fantastic four movie
he has the perfect body for not that
he's a tiny man he looks
[Laughter]
he's a little bit younger than me and
i'm old
how old
56
56
uh that's pretty big are you sure that
silver paint was because of that and not
something could have been he could have
been making out with uh um one of those
guys that freezes on the on the sidewalk
and pretends to be a statue it was
huffington's
bank
it could have been what if he was going
out for the new
you're losing your device
[Laughter]
zach what if timothy shalamay the god is
also auditioning for mad max because you
know they're coming out with the second
one
yeah blood boy or whatever they're
called yeah the blood boys love boys
that's a different reference but i love
it still and then
we need something uh real shiny uh to
attract something really clickbaity this
is brand new and breaking
20 minutes ago calabasas commons pete
davidson walks out he has broken up with
kim kardashian is now
stooping the casting director for uh
fantastic four and he's now mr fantastic
by popular demand of celebrity women
we'll see
him uh being able to increase the length
of any body part would explain a lot yes
hey now
don't dream it's over
it's a wonderful cast uh whitney uh
because you got my brain going uh you
may have a seat oh hell yeah what are
you doing
tommy i will say the the way this
segment ends was not quite figured out
but uh
we miss you i think you have to keep
standing okay as you go to the next
segment that was mandatory fun
thank you and now we're getting into
another segment that's my segment
if phillip would stop stretching over me
can we get the box box yeah okay so
james gunn in a series of tweets has now
confirmed that guardians of the galaxy
holiday special will take place in
between thor four so thor eleven thunder
and guardians of galaxy uh
three
so
but there i want i didn't know if we had
the asset of the tweets that he posted
there he is there we go there it is he's
right now it's coming hot he is
responding to people on twitter so go
ahead and tweet at him we'll probably
respond to you um
there's a lot of things that we do know
about so in the holiday special he says
that not everyone's going to be in the
original cast
which is interesting because if it takes
place it means if it takes place between
thor 4 and guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 that means we're missing a lot
of
a lot of freaking people yeah not a lot
of effort well gamora not currently a
member of the guardians of the galaxy
right post end game
it's a different gamora oh that is true
she's off on her own and this also takes
place on earth
gives her the divine opportunity to
ditch chris pratt and see her all just
leave just be like this guy sucks so
this is after that we still have okay so
we still we have no gamora but we still
have nebula
so i have rocket
uh we still have like everybody right
except for just gamora
after end game yeah we got him
so it's not
i guess maybe he's referring to only
gamora being taken out
but
there could be a chance that we bring on
somebody else that we haven't seen yet
or seen too much of it i'm going to be
honest i can't do this i can't do this
zach you can sit down i respect the
integrity of mandatory fun i think tommy
just forgot to write an ending for it
i do too i just have legs tommy
intentionally didn't write an ending for
it so that we'd have to suffer i love
that tommy thinks the worst punishment
you could give someone is standing
uh okay uh one thing i want to touch on
with this james gunn uh thing are these
tweets
i saw a tweet of james gunn talking
about uh height anybody see this tweet
no
it was like actors can you do me a favor
don't lie about your heights when you
come in uh in person it's very
uncomfortable for us if your height is
not what you said it was gonna be and it
hurts casting and then yeah yeah and
then uh the actor who plays black bull
uh quote tweeted it and was like uh or
how about height shouldn't matter uh and
really you're focusing on the wrong
thing and it should be talent or
whatever
and that was already like oh there's a
little bit of drama uh but then later
james gunn tweets oh he's like i want to
clarify i i don't uh i just don't like
people lying or something or whatever uh
and i think his name's anthony mount the
black bolt actor uh then quote tweeted
that and said something like how about
you just get some talent and delete your
account
whoa
claymore wow
i love other celebrities that are also
superheroes that fight james gunn
because it's just i mean it's clear this
is about anson mountain somewhere yeah
hit a button there clearly about height
yeah and like having tried to work with
james gunn on something
well he's not showing up in this yeah
he's probably not gonna be in it oh my
why do we think it's only taking place
on earth
hmm well
you pointed out like part of what makes
this a holiday special and not a
full-blown movie is it's going to be
shorter yes this could almost be like
one act from one of the guardians of the
galaxy movies right or a side quest
right maybe in fact maybe it is kind of
a side quest to earth for some reason
right it also is this was a horrible
idea
to eat this
exactly in the exact moment in which
you're gonna have to start talking also
i got you oh my god you keep taking my
snacks okay so
what i was gonna say is it's gonna be on
disney plus it is very short so it would
give more way for it just to be like
a snippet but i want it to be more than
a snippet i don't want to be just like a
little take you know and also is do we
know it's not like a it's like just a
short it's not a series right no it's
going to be like a one hour one hour
yeah do you think it's going to kind of
mimic what we got with deadpool's
holiday special
just as bad as jessica why did you take
a bite right before you spoke look if
i'm not allowed to eat and talk i'm not
going to talk again oh my god wait uh
isn't it can't you just see peter quill
saying something like you're telling me
the guardians of the galaxy get to save
christmas
oh it's all about like that kind of
thing or whatever oh are we going to get
a childhood an evil santa
uh
always an evil or somebody posing yeah
the sabrina chilling adventures of
sabrina christmas special oh god satan's
coming together we're gonna get mephisto
is coming to town and we're gonna have a
[ __ ] place mephisto confirmed
james gunn fan of the channel slips that
went to his uh holiday special
the academy if you guys are all watching
come on
please it's referred to as a holiday
special so i still think there's gonna
be some holiday stuff in it i think it's
also gonna appeal to not only just one
holiday we're we're working with people
that are guardians of the galaxy not
guardians of america so
they're going to handle the guardians of
america
guardians of america and in theory right
like all of the guardians maybe even
including peter quill don't really know
earth tradition so they could be just
celebrating it could be them learning
about christmas right like or just them
like celebrating their own holiday
together and calling it like rocket day
or something yeah i want to eat that
christmas is the friends you made along
the way
well what do you think they'll say that
i bet they'll go over the meaning of
christmas what do you think it will be
and then how do you think that uh drax
will misinterpret it
all right uh well i don't know if any i
feel like all of us are equally wrong
and it probably will be almost exactly
what we just said well and i i think
we're probably getting set up for some
really fun surprises right like because
there's no precedent for this did say it
was canon so like there's a lot of that
you have to hold on to and when we say
cannon we know that guardians of
galaxy's kind of done but it's like
now he could put something in here that
we all have to
philip i swear he just dropped his
treatment no i didn't
the camera caught it on my foot um that
they have to follow throughout the rest
of the mcu gun also he had a bunch of
details about the soundtrack it's going
to have its own soundtrack including
some original songs original which is
interesting yeah maybe maybe like
wouldn't it be dope i love christmas
music and you know it's rare that like a
new christmas song gets added to kind of
the canon you know so many of those
songs are from like the 50s and the 60s
you know there's like mariah carey's all
i want for christmas is you and that's
kind of like the most recent
like
classic wouldn't it be fun if he's
attempting to add his own classic to the
mix wouldn't it be great if he just got
mariah carey oh
he's gonna have a cr do you think he has
a christmas mix
yeah
it's gonna be a christmas mix though the
other ones were so cool it is this music
isn't cool yeah
so cool there could be there's some good
rock you know christmas i i am
if you can't tell by the everything
about me i love a very she and him
christmas but that's the only album is
that the one with is that the edition
yeah there's always another one can you
not tell by my bangs what band i'm
talking about
my favorite uh christmas song is carol
of the bells
i don't know why but i can know how to
perform it in sign language which
doesn't make sense okay because it's for
bells i can sing silent night in german
i'm not gonna wow
and your parents are on vacation
i'm proud of both of you guys we've got
we've got some great super chats we want
to get to
uh sorry i just noticed chrissy
thank you chrissy say it you can see yes
chrissy our our good friend and
egyptologist coming through as always
with the great facts i thought her
headpiece i think this is referring to
the who we are guessing is the best
character from that love and thunder
photo thank you john uh i thought her
headpiece had a
you reyes
uh that's uh
yeah the rearing cobra denoting royalty
but her outfit doesn't really look
historically egyptian it looks more of a
modern african design than anything so
that would kind of be more evidence i
think it's the best and also we um just
to reiterate what brandon has said what
we said that they do mention best uh
black panther like as that's their god
so i'm like
a more african design a more african
queen best yeah i just want it in there
uh lewis berry or could be louie berry i
don't know how you pronounce that uh
hope they keep footage of gore from thor
four hidden
uh toby and andrew's style can't wait to
see bale and the movie oh yeah they
could have definitely just scrapped
scraped a lot of that stuff out that we
didn't see in the trailer how long have
we been live for
uh
like how much under an hour
great let's do a few minutes of q a yeah
okay great uh somebody's question let's
see evan hansen says both daddies are
here today question mark
uh yes jessica and whitney both didn't
make it in today someone did call me
oh wait we can do this now oh that's why
we haven't been able to see this
also the poll says for who had the best
rumor uh jessica with 42 percent whitney
with 30 zaddy with 26. okay this is the
first i never win the moment
clearly the polls are just off today
because are you hyped for the barbie
movie
no 68
well you say that now but wait till we
spend the next 41 days straight
promoting barbie news
yeah new rockstars is going to shift to
an entirely barbie-only channel exactly
the bcu barbie uh
at what was it we lost it at jb db or
something uh said that they could give
50 for your dab
thank you uh well you know what here's
one for free oh my god oh it was too
fast it was too fast one more time
cameron couldn't catch it
there's a third one for free wow and
reminder he said it's soulja boy when he
did it the first time
he did he said hey the confidence watch
me whip watch me
oh my god you said the dance moves and
still did the dance wrong that's a good
idea
uh jessica you look sickening thank you
yeah jessica the only reason i watched
the only reason you shouldn't i'm joking
thank you oh we got a good one there
from matthew moreno saying i thought
mordo would be in agatha house of
harkness since it's the second
supernatural marvel series besides moon
knight who else could even be in agatha
well
because they said that elizabeth olsen
is not going up here in it well she's
saying that we don't know if that will
turn out to be true i want yeah and it's
also she said as of now they probably
are just gonna
summer in really quick but i do want i
pitch this i love killing people off and
i love being a villain more than
anything but i want agatha to end up
with white vision i want her to be
mimicking wanda and vision like that's
very funny like they're going like
double dates
because we you talked about how just
because of which is dead doesn't mean
the power is gone yeah right the spell
is still there so i was like what if
she's awakened by white vision because
it's the closest that she can get to
normal vision because i don't think
you're going to create a spell that's
like keeping in mind the hardest part of
your life like the memory of like the
worst moment of your life so i want to
be awakened by it i also say the post
credit of doctor strange gave us a new
magic wielder and clia
but uh we see charlize theron show up
and i get the house of harvard could you
imagine she just like
she's like shut up bat and like it hits
the back of catherine hahn and the power
goes out
shut up i like life of eyes uh a theory
here that they hope uh gore kills santa
what i like about that is that santa is
a god santa is a god
yeah
he's as powerful as the other gods oh
for sure so bryce burris bryce burruss
said would y'all rather have lone bee in
multiverse match maybe i think
yeah
my multivitamins instead of john
what uh that way we could save john for
the actual fantastic four movie
i think
did you guys like him uh as a duster
well the thing is i've been rooting for
him for
ever since someone said
uh for john and this is i think
specifically referring to the actor who
played mr fantastic in the previous two
fox movies
rise of silver surfer it's a it's a
welsh first name so it's got nothing but
vowels maybe i would have loved it but i
would have thought they would have
probably had to like create so much
hurdles to jump over if they did
oh
it's his office at the end of the day
he's our boss yeah he can do whatever he
wants i want this and then force me to
clean it up later that is not true don't
say that that is not funny
is gonna be so mad at me um but i would
love that i would love that i also love
those call backs but i just think they
would probably have to do so many
hurdles uh do you think that heck's
design for the library racks and the
original doctor strange has significance
in what we have learned about chaos
magic so summer bee interesting ooh yeah
you remember like all the locks that
were on the the shelves uh when he was
when was the dark hole in there
i don't know if the dark hole was but
he's accessing books that he's not
supposed to yeah when he's supposed to
get in all those are yeah they're in the
heck straight well
ah
have we not talked about that has vos
not talked about i feel like someone has
probably talked about that because i
thought they didn't want to use that
same magic that wanda was using wand is
using darkhold magic i guess
so does that make sense you guys are
coming but don't say the hex is like is
that different magic but that's that's
that's that's that's what it's like like
does marvel know what the hex is like
so that is true so many things yeah it's
just a cool kind of shape it's the
coolest thing yeah that and the s that
you make out of six lines yes yeah yeah
followed by the dodecahedron uh big
random said why don't you guys ever use
the arcade machine as part of the break
room like a compilation segment or even
as part of mandatory fun
you see how hard it took daschle to zoom
in on that
that is why we haven't used it the
little uh bts uh tommy spends about an
hour before every filming playing that
game so trust us it's getting used he's
not live
he doesn't have the top scores on it
somehow so like the only person that's
played on it i don't like this i want to
try it there hasn't been one treat in
this box and i'm not joking the only one
i haven't liked
uh well speaking of treats this has been
a treat connecting with you guys thank
you so much for watching thank you sweet
treats yes thank you whitney and phillip
filling in uh jessica thank you for
being here all the time
is there always going to be food
yeah you know what every day this week
there will be really yes
yeah let me know if you want me to come
back i will remember the chat said gore
vs jesus i love it gloria versus jesus i
got you right now i'm gonna i want that
so bad but like america will never allow
it i'll do it there's too many there's
too many christians who would be mad but
i want gore to fight
jesus i want gore to fight me and then
maybe piss me on the lips
but thanks a little but i want lord i
want gore to fight white jesus obviously
oh like the anglo-white jesus yes white
jesus and black santa and white white
jesus is um that is the the version of
jesus that wanda has brought back from
her dead husband yes exactly yeah yeah
yeah the cold unfeeling version why are
you bringing everybody back that's white
we'll be back every day this week at
roughly 3 p.m pacific you know it's a
bit of a roll that dice will win we're
going to get started uh but tune in yeah
someone said r2d2 and i'll give it one
for free this week without tommy here
on that note thank you all bye bye keep
it good
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you